Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we will see that modern
AIs can not only generate images,
but they can also make them come alive. Oh yes.
Now, as all of you know, we already have a bunch
of text to image AIs around, OpenAI’s DALL-E 2,
and a free variant, Stable Diffusion and more.
Here, we enter a text prompt, and it paints
a beautiful image for us that satisfies our
prompt. And whenever I create such an image,
I am always wondering, what if we could also
use this AI to actually edit these images or
you know what, maybe even videos to our liking?
Today we will find out whether that is possible.
And wait, today, images are not the only thing
we can generate with these techniques. As of
2022 October, Google’s Imagen Video
AI is also out there, and with this,
we have not just text to image, but text
to video. And the results are truly insane.
And this work from scientists at Google, this is
a little different. It builds on StyleGAN instead,
this is not a text to image AI, but a generative
model. The visual quality it can create is simply
astounding. Just look at that. And get this,
this new paper just added a bunch of amazing
text to video-like features to it. Now,
it can take a generative model like this,
and create a video for us, but we can
choose what should happen in this video.
How? Well, first, we give it a bunch of images,
for instance about horses and it now generates
new, high-quality images within this domain.
But, here is the key - these images are generated
by using a latent space. You see an example of a
latent space here from our previous paper which
helps an artist generate similar virtual material
models by exploring with this dot on a 2D plane.
Now, most of these technique guarantee that when
exploring nearby, we will get similar material
models, however, it seems almost impossible
to say for instance, that we wish to see more
metallic materials. We get similar materials, but
we can’t describe exactly what we are looking for.
However, hold on to your papers, because this
new technique claims that it can do exactly
that. Well, I will believe it when I see it.
Let’s see. Whoa! We can make this lion roar!
And many others too. And what I really love
about these results is that almost all of
the intermediate images that were generated fit
together so well that it seems like a believable,
continuous video. But that’s not all, it
can do a ton more. For instance, it can
rotate the heads of these parrots, and temporal
consistency is remarkably good here too, which
means that we don’t have a ton of flickering.
Now make no mistake, there is some, but these
are getting closer and closer to being believable
as actual video footage. What a time to be alive!
And if we have just the perfect parrot, but it
takes up just a bit too much of the frame, not a
problem, look, zooming in and out of images is
also possible, and it fills in the remaining parts
of the image with sensible information. More of
the parrot or more background. How cool is that!
And, if we have created the perfect horse image
with this AI, but we are yearning for a little
more action, not a problem. Look. It can even
make them run. Some of the intermediate images
are not perfect, so this might not pass as
a video, yet. But, as images, incredible.
The paper is available in the video description
and it is chock full of these incredible results.
And, you know what, let’s pop the hood
and look inside together! For instance,
they propose a new filtering step that supposedly
has magical powers. Does it? Let’s see. A somewhat
unorganized dataset comes in, for instance, these
can be made by another AI, we bunch them up,
throw it at the new neural network, and after
filtering them down to a smaller subset,
the new technique can generate significantly
better images than other methods could before.
How much better? Let’s see. Whoa. Look at that!
Other AIs prefer the results generated with the
new filtering step. That’s good news, but come
on, we are not computers, we are humans. Does
this really say anything about what humans prefer?
You bet your papers it does! Look! Humans are also
loving the results with the new technique. And
the difference is remarkable. So good. So, welcome
to Two Minute Papers, where we look at tables and
flip out together. Hope you’re enjoying it as much
as I do. So, what do you think? Does this get your
mind going? Let me know in the comments below!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!